Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Frohes drittes Jahr, Linus.
Frustrittes Jahr, Tim.
Logbuch, Dance-Politik Nummer 417 und äh wir schreiben das Jahr 20022. Wir kommen hier am 7. Januar zusammen und äh ja, da ist sie, die erste Sendung des neuen,
Jahres und ob's nun wirklich das dritte Pandemiejahr wird, ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher.
Was soll's denn sonst werden? Äh vierte.
Na ja, ich denke, ich denke, ich denke wir haben sogar eine Chance. Es ist kein drittes Jahr wird.
Also Tim, es ist bereits das dritte Jahr. Die die Frage ist äh in Deutschland? Also nee, die also okay, die.
Du weißt, eine Pandemie ist ja auch weltweit und so. Nimmst es ja wieder sehr genau.
Medi, also die die ich weiß nicht mehr das genaue Datum, aber es ist über zwei Jahre her, dass das Coronavirus bekannt wurde
Und damit sind wir jetzt nun mal im dritten Jahr. Du die Frage, die du dir stellst, ist, ob die Pandemie das dritte Jahr noch voll macht, glaube ich.
Nee, ob's ob's ähm in Deutschland das dritte Jahr noch antritt, sagen wir's mal so.
Okay. Also du glaubst in zwei Monaten ist es durch.
Ähm ja denke schon.
Okay, okay.
Auch erforderlich, um einfach Raum zu machen für die goldenen Zwanziger. Du weißt schon.
Jetzt verstehe ich wenigstens, warum die Leute uns immer bellt schreiben, dass sie unseren ungebrochenen Optimismus schätzen.
Ja. Ja. Du mit du bist ja immer hier der Dom, da musst du sie ja irgendwie ausgleichen. Nee, ich bin ganz optimistisch.
Okay, ja, nee.
Mit dem Angriff von Obicron wird das alles in Ordnung kommen.
Ja gut, dem lassen wir dem gehen wir auf jeden Fall gerade genug Raum, ja? Ich bin mal gespannt, also ich meine, die hätte nichts dagegen. Ähm ich hänge nicht an der Pandemie-Time, ne. Also.
Wirklich? Ach du meinst, du könntest jetzt auch mal ohne.
Jetzt ich finde gut ich meine jetzt wo man sich so sehr dran gewöhnt hat,
Wahrscheinlich auch wieder eine Umstellung. Ging dir das nicht auch schon so im Sommer, das dachtest so, ah ja jetzt wollen die mir bei alle Spieler so nahe kommen und so.
Hm nö, das habe ich.
Nee, da man hat eher so seine äh die Erwartungen, die dann irgendwie anders sind und nicht erfüllt werden. Das war jetzt hier gerade der die gekontoüberleitung zu deinem HTTP Statuscode.
Ja genau, wir wollen ja nach wie vor die Statuscodes euch näher äh bringen und um ehrlich zu sein
auch uns. So richtig ausführlich studiert, habe ich die auch noch nie und äh insofern ist es mal ganz interessant, dass äh sich mal zu ähm
zu geben. Wir sind jetzt bei Nummer 417 und die hat den wunderschönen Namen
Expectation fehlt. Das kennen wir natürlich alle auf eine gewisse Art und Weise, ne? Allerdings ist es halt auch wieder so ein Klassiker
Insofern, als dass das so eine
definierter Statuscode ist, wo sich die Entwickler irgendwie mal gedacht haben, ja, was brauchen wir bestimmt und so, dass man erstmal einen dafür definieren. Es gibt da irgendwie auch nur irgendwie einen einzigen Usecase und den benutzt wohl kaum einer. Also kein kein Browser unterstützt das äh äh wirklich. Von daher handelt es sich hier eher um totes Material.
Aber äh das bietet natürlich dann die Möglichkeit, diesen wunderschönen Fehlercode vielleicht für.
Anderer anderer artige Interpretationen freizugeben, zum Beispiel politischer Art.
Haben ja derzeit so diverse die äh sicherlich auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise mal irgendwann mal fehlen werden und dann kann man da einfach sagen, ja vierhundertsiebzehn, ne, ja, hm ja,
so so ein bisschen wie dieser dieser Witz mit in dem Witzeclub wo alle den Witz schon äh kennen und gar nicht mehr zu Ende erzählen wollen
die Witze einfach nur noch bezahlen äh referenzieren ne und aber wenn wenn dann halt einer nicht lacht, dann war er halt Scheiße erzählt.
Kannst du so nicht machen. Nee, nee.
Vierhundertsiebzehn, ne? Ja.
Wir haben Shirts. Verkauft haben wir.
Genau und unten Mails dazu bekommen, tatsächlich. Also ähm ich Programmierer machen ja oft bei One Evers,
äh Hörerinnen auch. Einige von euch haben oft bei One Airs gebracht, weil ich in der Sendung gesagt habe zwanzig dreiundzwanzig habt ihr euren LNP-Merch und einige haben halt gedacht, ich hätte damit versprochen, zwanzig,
einundzwanzig oder mit Beginn 202zwanzig tatsächlich ähm ist es so, also wenn man mit,
auch nochmal konferiert, weil wir einige unglückliche Leute haben, die ihre Lieferung noch nicht erhalten haben. Äh die Situation ist folgende,
Hm sagen wir mal so, der äh die Menge die bestellte Menge lag etwas über der von mir äh prognostizierten Menge.
Sodass es äh jetzt äh zu einer Nachbestellung kommen musste, also die Rohware musste nachbestellt werden in bestimmten,
Größen, also bestimmte Größen mussten neu bestellt werden und ähm das ist ein Problem, was ich auch schon vom Kongress immer kenne. Du musst,
dauert teilweise halt echt einfach mal vier Wochen oder sowas, bis du halt eine neue Lieferung bekommst. Vor allem äh wenn Pandemie ist und ähm Dezember und deswegen gibt's jetzt noch einen.
Sagen wir mal prozentual,
kleinen aber absolut immer noch recht also ist trotzdem signifikanter Teil an Leuten die ihre äh Lieferung einfach noch nicht erhalten haben und zu eurem Trostmarkt gehören äh ich auch noch nicht.
Meine meine Bestellung ist auch noch nicht da. Was ich jetzt, sage ich mal, von Ticket-Toaster auch nur so halbsmart finde
das nicht, wenigstens sehe ich meinen Shit bekomme, aber äh das zeigt eben auch einfach nur, dass sie's nach Best-Eford gemacht haben und ich war eben nicht äh der Erste, der bestellt hat, sondern der Letzte.
Ähm insofern äh ja kriege ich's, kriege ich's halt auch bisher noch nicht.
Um's mal zu konkretisieren, also ungefähr so 15 Prozent der Bestellungen stehen noch aus. So, also die allermeisten von euch sind schon äh beglückt worden und ähm habt uns das auch wissen lassen, was ich äh sehr schön fand, äh vor allem auf,
Twitter wurde dann doch das ein oder andere äh Foto gepostet und äh.
Paar in den ich fürchte
ich hoffe, dass ich da keins äh übersehen habe, aber ich weiß, dass ich eins habe, dass äh bestimmt mehrere übersehen habe, aber das Schönste fand ich tatsächlich von Johannes, der äh am,
Vormittag des 25. Dezembers äh sich selbst und ich würde jetzt mal schätzen, sein Vater beide auf Twitter mit dem,
gleichen Shirt und äh der äh Unterschrift zwei Doofer ein Gedanke.
Oder oder seinen Sohn. Also wir wissen ja jetzt nicht, wem der Account gehört.
Genau ja genau also zwei können auch vielleicht sind einfach nur Kumpels ja so wie du und ich, ich will ja auch nicht dein Sohn.
Jetzt bricht für alle eine Welt zusammen.
Linus, ich bin dein Vater.
Na ja und äh genau, vielleicht sind wir einfach in Kumpels, aber auf jeden Fall haben die sich äh gegenseitig das Shirt geschenkt. Und sich dann äh das ist doch äh eine coole äh.
Einem nicht nicht ein Shirt sondern genau auch noch das dasselbe Modell, ne? Das schicke.
Ist schon sehr.
Ist wirklich hübsch geworden ist, also das äh finde ich ganz toll.
Sieht auf jeden Fall gut aus. Äh ich hab's ja noch nicht.
Auch nicht.
Aber fand äh das äh war natürlich das konnte man dann nicht mehr toppen und äh habe haben wir uns sehr drüber hm gefreut.
Ja, wir verlinken ein paar von den äh schönen Fotos.
Genau, die Tweets, die uns so erreicht haben mit Bild und ja. Freuen wir.
Haben wir für coole Hörerinnen auch.
Ne? So da haben wir zwei kurze gute Nachrichten, Tim.
Zwei kurze gute Nachrichten oh ho ho ho, jetzt übertreibst du's aber.
Und zwar hatte der Bundestag ja im Juni, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, beschlossen.
Dass ähm die Bundespolizei und alle 19 Nachrichtendienste des Bundes und der Länder,
Staatstrojaner Befugnis bekommen, also ähm ne die Benutzung von Staatsrändern das ausrollen.
Was äh damals wir hier auch sehr ausführlich diskutiert haben ähm und das war ein ein besonders
kritischer Aspekt war
dass die Bundespolizei das präventiv darf, also nicht nur im Rahmen der Strafverfolgung, sondern präventiv. Du hast also noch gar keine Straftat begangen und dein Handy darf gehackt
werden, dass äh die Geheimdienste das machen, weil die Geheimdienste müssen ja sehr viel weniger ähm.
Äh äh sich rechtfertigen für das, was sie tun. Da gibt's auch keinen äh Richtervorbehalt. Und ähm dann,
Um das alles zu ermöglichen, hatten Sie auch geplant, dass quasi Telekommunikationsanbieter verpflichtet werden.
Aufspielen von Überwachungssoftware zu helfen.
Ähm das war der in also ich meine die sind alle kritisch diese Punkte aber quasi deine deine Telekommunikationsanbieter.
Dazu zu verpflichten, gegen deine Interessen zu agieren und dein Handy mit einer Scherzerfahrt zu versehen. Ist ja wirklich ein sehr
äh großes ein ein ein sehr äh übles Vorgehen oder eine sehr schlechte Idee, weil ja hier direkt in das Vertrauensverhältnis einbrichst,
und es geht eben nicht jetzt, was weiß ich, um die Leitung, die sie dir bereitstellen, sondern dein persönliches Gerät, welches daneben gehackt werden soll. Ähm
Man muss gar nicht unbedingt sagen, dass sie außerdem bei der Telekommunikationsanbieter natürlich falsch sind, denn sie müssten eigentlich wahrscheinlich eher bei den,
Anbietern oder bei Apple Google antreten. Langer Rede kurzer Sinn, dieses Vorhaben hat,
im September äh im Dezember dann den Bundesrat nicht passiert. Also der Bundesrat im Bundesrat war das Gesetz zustimmungspflichtig ist, hat sich keine
Mehrheit für diese Mitwirkungspflicht gefunden.
Und dementsprechend wird die nicht.
Kommen, ja? So wie es aussieht haben das die Grünen und die FDP,
äh gestoppt, so interpretiere ich das jetzt hier ähm
primär, weil FDP sich dazu äußert und ich die Info von den äh Grünen bekommen habe. Ähm kurz nachdem das da entschieden wurde und äh das ist ja erstmal eine gute Nachricht.
Das ist definitiv eine gute Nachricht und äh ist überhaupt bisher alles recht entspannt, was so äh aus dem Bundesjustizministerium an frühen Maßnahmen gekommen ist, sind ja auch noch ein paar andere Sachen,
schon behandelt worden, Vorratsdatenspeicherung hatten wir schon drüber gesprochen,
die jetzt äh sozusagen nicht gerade ganz oben auf der Agenda äh sitzt und natürlich dann auch so nicht nützpolitische Aspekte wie diese sinnlose äh Abtreibungs-Werbungsverbot für äh.
Oh ja, boah, was ein Wahnsinn.
Und so was, also einfach einfach so no brainer der letzten Jahrzehnte,
einfach so mit dem Generations und dann eben auch mit dem Politwechsel, den eben so eine neue Regierung dann zwangsläufig mit sich bringt, dann so schnell unter dieses so ja okay, können wir das jetzt endlich mal lassen, die sinnlosen.
Das das das ist immer das Schöne an solchen Momenten. Ich meine, wir werden noch.
Genug haben, wo wir uns aufregen werden und wo's äh mal wieder in eine Richtung läuft, die kritikwürdig äh ist, mit Sicherheit. Aber grad so der Beginn einer Regierung ist natürlich erstmal damit verbunden, dass so diese ganzen Sachen, wo die überhaupt keinen Bock mehr haben zu diskutieren, weil das ist eigentlich schon alles diskutiert ist und nur noch von der
CDU verhindert wurde. Äh das wird dann halt einfach jetzt mal schnell zu Akten gelegt und dann kann man sich in das äh wichtige Zeug kümmern.
Muss man auch ganz einfach sagen, mit der FDP im Justizministerium sind wir auch von 2009 bis 2013 nicht so schlecht gefahren.
Sabine Schnarrenberger ja also schöne Grüße an Herrn Buschmann, hat ein Vorbild. Der sich gerne orientieren kann.
Genau. Ja.
Mhm das war die eine gute Nachricht und.
Eine gute Nachricht.
Eine gute Nachricht. Und zwar äh gibt es jetzt.
Ähm zwei Verbraucherschutzgesetzivellierungen im Bürgerlichen Gesetzbuch, die wir auch hier begleitet haben und damit gilt die Sätzen eine EU,
Richtlinie um, ja ähm und zwar die EU-Waren, Kaufrichtlinie von 2019 und da wird im BGB quasi ergänzt, was für Basisanforderungen, für Verträge,
über die Bereitstellung,
digitaler Produkte gilt. Ja und das war das ist quasi die Umsetzung der EU-Richtlinie für digitale Inhalte und,
Dienstleistungen.
Und äh was das bedeutet ist, digitale Produkte kann man jetzt quasi zurückgeben und zwar auch die äh sogenannten kostenlosen, wo du nicht mit Geld bezahlst, sondern mit deinen Daten.
Ja, da gibt's also quasi ein Rückgaberecht und,
ähm da quasi so Updates im Durchschnitt für fünf Jahre müssen ungefähr äh bereitgestellt werden,
ne ähm bei Mängeln an dem Produkt gibt's dann eine längere Beweislastumkehr.
Und das heißt, hier wird jetzt zum ersten Mal so ein gewisser,
Anspruch ähm auf die Software, die du irgendwie als Kunde dir andrehen lässt. Äh gültig und auch rechtlich durchsetzbar und als Markt,
Äh Markt erfordernis äh definiert und das ist schon mal ein guter Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Richtig verstanden habe, gilt diese äh Beweislast-Umkehr jetzt gar nicht mal nur für diese digitalen Produkte, sondern generell ist das sozusagen jetzt eine Abkehr von dem bisher gültigen sechs Monaten auf äh einen Monat, also was so die Gewährleistung
betrifft aber das gilt natürlich auch hier. Äh ich würde noch ergänzen, dass
in dem Gesetz nicht genau festgelegt ist, wie lange diese Update-Pflicht ist, sondern dass sie quasi in so einer Kalkulation davon
ausgegangen sind, dass so fünf Jahre, so das ist, von dem sie annehmen, dass es irgendwie okay ist, aber es ist halt jetzt noch nicht fest geregelt. Was das dann bedeutet, muss man mal schauen, weil das bedeutet ja, dass es jetzt zwangsläufig dann vor Gerichten entschieden werden muss.
Denn jetzt hier sozusagen noch ein Update hm Verpflichtung besteht für das eine oder andere Produkt äh frage mich halt auch, wie das dann letztlich verankert wird, weil man irgendeine Richtlinie muss es ja geben, sonst würde das ja dann eben erst in den nächsten Jahren mit
entsprechenden Entscheidungen
bei Gerichten quasi nachträglich festgestellt werden, sodass man sagt, was weiß ich, DSL Rauter muss mindestens fünf Jahre, aber dein äh Christmas Light ähm reicht auch irgendwie zwei Jahre oder so, ne.
Und das äh erscheint mir noch ein bisschen unklar zu sein, aber äh schon mal besser, dass es das jetzt grundsätzlich gibt und jetzt muss man halt gucken, wie das ausgestattet wird.
Genau, das muss jetzt mal ausgemalt werden. Also das ist ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung, sicherlich noch nicht in der vollen Stränge, aber hier gibt's jetzt mal vernünftigen Verbraucher oder hier gibt's jetzt mal überhaupt eine Basis,
für den Verbraucherschutz und ähm das ist auch muss man sagen eine Forderung die wir sehr lange schon äh hatten,
und ähm das wird sicherlich nicht uninteressant.
Ich würde aber auf jeden Fall auch sagen, da muss wird jetzt noch in wahrscheinlich in tja die die wie nennt man das denn dann? Die das gelebte Recht muss man dann jetzt mal noch sehen.
Und dann werden sich sicherlich auch irgendwelche Anpassungen, Ergänzungen oder so was in in den nächsten Jahren ergeben. Ist ja häufig.
Nicht so gute Nachricht, Tim. Äh wir wollen ja, dass das äh Coronavirus endemisch wird. Aber jetzt äh geht es offenbar auch darum, dass die Corona-Apps endemisch werden wollen.
Und da haben sich jetzt tatsächlich hm einige ja ich will mal sagen interessante ähm Entwicklungen ergeben.
Und zwar fangen wir mal mit der Corona-Warn-App an. Die hat jetzt in der neusten Version,
Ein Feature, das sich Remote Validation nennt.
So, was ist äh was soll das lösen? Also welche Probleme will man hier lösen?
Wenn du also ich ich das beste Beispiel,
Was wäre von diesem Feature profitieren wird und wer das sicherlich auch äh gerne haben wollte, äh ist eine Airline, ja? Ähm wenn du jetzt mal irgendwie in letzter Zeit geflogen bist, äh die Airline-Situation ist so, du buchst dieses Ticket, die sagen dir dann, okay, pass auf
Beachte bitte die geltenden Einreisebestimmungen. Die informieren dich natürlich auch so gut wie möglich darüber und sagen, was mal hier guckst du beim Auswärtigen Amt oder sonst was.
Aber was äh regelmäßig zu chaotischen Situationen führt, ist wenn zum Beispiel ein Land sich jetzt mal.
Relativ kurzfristig entschieden hat, was weiß ich, bei Einreise aus Deutschland verlangen wir einen ähm PCR-Test.
Und wir verpflichten übrigens auch die Airlines, die dieses das Vorliegen dieses PCR-Test vorher zu prüfen. Ja, dann bist du in der Situation, dass beim Boarding.
Das Personal, das normalerweise einfach nur kurz guckt, dass äh weißt du, wenn bei uns Senatorin früher einsteigen dürfen, so ungefähr, ja, die müssen jetzt auf einmal,
die,
Impfpässe noch kontrollieren oder potenziell PCR-Nachweise und was nicht alles. Und da hast du natürlich dann Kulleraugen, weil irgendwelche Leute haben das Memo wieder nicht gekriegt und dann dürfen die nicht mitfliegen und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen.
Ja, also Problemstellung, wir würden gerne bei der Buchung eines Tickets beispielsweise online.
Und schon mal das Vorliegen eines Impfnachweises bestätigen lassen und diesen prüfen
was da heute gemacht wird, weil es keine andere Lösung gibt, ist, mache bitte einen Screenshot, ne oder ein Foto von,
dem äh QR-Code, den du da hast, lad das irgendwie hoch. Ähm Spanien beispielsweise hat dafür eine eigenes Webportal beziehungsweise eine eigene App, aber letztendlich der einzige Weg, den sie haben, ist ähm,
schickt bitte also machen Screenshot oder QR-Code oder sowas, so lade den hoch, ne. Ähm,
Ticketverkauf ist das Gleiche, deswegen lass uns einfach mal beim beim Flug bleiben für das Beispiel, damit's nicht äh allzu viel allzu komplizierter wird, weil der Flug ist gleichzeitig auch schon der komplizierteste Fall. So ähm.
Das ist das Problem, was Sie gerne lösen möchten, ja? Ähm was gefällt Ihnen am Status Quonig? Na ja,
letztendlich eigentlich nur, dass es halt umständlich ist, Screenshot hochladen und so weiter, ne? Also ist ein Prozess, der jetzt sage ich mal
viele Menschen potenziell äh überfordert, ja oder eine hohe Anforderung ist. Das heißt, man möchte hier die Usability ähm erhöhen
und dann ergibt sich natürlich auch das Problem.
Wer ist jetzt eigentlich verantwortlich dafür, dass diese Prüfung auch ordnungsgemäß stattfindet und zwar diese Remote-Prüfung? Ähm,
Letztendlich in dem QR-Code steht ja nur drin, ne Personenname, Impfstatus, ähm Geburtsdatum, glaube ich, und ähm dann halt eine Signatur dahinter, ja und,
Man könnte jetzt zum Beispiel die erste Möglichkeit diesen Prozess zu vereinfachen, wäre, dass man nicht einen QR-Code hochladen muss, sondern einfach den textlichen Inhalt des QR-Codes.
Der den anderen zugänglich macht, ne? Das wäre so die der erste Schritt der Vereinfachung, weil dann sparst du dir auf der Verifikationsseite schon mal den
QR-Code äh Dekoder, ja? Also kannst du kannst du sehr viel Ressourcen sparen und Ärger sparen, wenn du einfach sagst, okay,
Schick mal bitte den String.
Ist schon gescannt sozusagen.
Ja, das äh der QR-Code ist ja quasi eine Komplizierung der Angelegenheit. Ja ähm so da was da welches Problem bleibt.
Du hast jetzt eine Sammlung von Gesundheitsdaten bei diesen Privatanbietern.
Keiner weiß, wer die sind, was die machen, wie sie die speichern. Die haben im Zweifelsfall auch keine Lust,
jetzt auf einmal andere DSGVO Geschichten zu haben, weil sie mit Gesundheitsdaten agieren, ja? Und zweitens,
Wer bürgt den, also wer gibt denen die Software, die garantiert? Du hast das richtig geprüft, weil was ist denn, wenn die jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen irgendeine veraltete Version des Checks machen und irgendein Zertifikat falsch
anerkennen
ja? Oder fälschlicherweise ablehnen und ne also immer wenn die da eine falsche Entscheidung treffen würden, kann die potenziell sehr blöde Konsequenzen haben. Ich sage nicht, dass das wahrscheinlich ist, dass dieser Fall auch eintritt. Ich sage nur, dass sich natürlich jeder juristisch darum.
Ergard, wenn das der Fall ist. So, ich denke, das ist das, das ist jetzt der äh das ist so das.
Anwendungsgebiet, ja? Es gibt ähm Anbieter, allen voran die Airlines, aber nicht nur, die gerne dieses Feature hätten. Es gibt ähm,
Personen, die an ein in Einlassschlangen stehen, die sich auch freuen, wenn Sachen zügiger gehen.
Und ähm jetzt könnte man sagen, ich habe ja gerade mal so naiv gesagt, dann nimmst du einfach den String aus dem QR-Code und schickst den rüber und,
lässt den dort verifizieren ja? Jetzt,
hättest du aber äh also jetzt ist noch die Frage, wie schaffst du das jetzt, den darüber zu schicken? Da muss man natürlich irgendwie ein Protokoll definieren, ne? Könnte man sagen, na du, du zeigst einen QR-Code
der dann für die Corona-Warn-App der Endpunkt ist, wo die dann eben mal kurz ihren Impf-String hinschickt und Problem, die aufmerksame Hörerin erinnert sich direkt an der ID Wallet. Ja, das ist nämlich, wenn man so was dann mit QR-Codes macht, dann kann jeder da irgendwie
Irgendwohin Staaten schicken lassen und dann hast du potenziell da eine Sicherheitslücke. Also, was haben sich die.
CWA-Leute und übrigens nicht nur die, sondern auch direkt auf Höhe der Europäischen Union. Überlegt, na ja, wir machen einfach,
Trusted Validation Services.
Ja also nee du schickst nicht deinen Impfpass direkt an den Anbieter, wo er dann entsprechenden äh Problemen unterliegt, dass der den vielleicht scheiße prüft oder wie er da rechtlich ist oder die Daten zu lange speichert oder oder oder. Sondern.
Wir machen dazwischen einen Service, der quasi diese Validierung vornimmt. Wir machen in der Corona-Warn-App stellen wir sicher, dass sie nur mit autorisierten Services redet und auch nur denen ihren ähm
Impfstatus verrät, ja, also den Impfpass mitteilt und so weiter und die teilen dann wiederum dem anderen Ende mit, jo, alles klar, hier äh diese Person, wir wir bestätigen hiermit das
Person XY gerade einen Impfpass folgender Provenienz äh vorgelegt hat, ja.
Oder generell einfach die Anforderungen, die in dem Fall äh erfüllt werden müssen, dass die erfüllt werden, ohne weitere Details zu nennen. Einfach nur ein Passshow oder Pass.
Richtig richtig so. Also ne es soll ein Valleyation Service.
Und ähm man muss jetzt dazu sagen, äh der der der Test, den der macht ist relativ einfach, der muss halt nur sicher sein, ne und du hast es gerade gesagt, es gibt ja unterschiedliche,
Rulesets. Deswegen habe ich jetzt auch immer direkt mit den Airlines angefangen, weil die könnten potenziell,
ne? Für jedes Land sagen okay pass auf, mit dem Impfpass kannst du nach ähm was weiß ich nach Portugal darfst du aber äh nach Spanien nicht oder ne.
Nach China nicht, ja.
Nach China nicht oder äh äh und so weiter.
Dann könnte man das natürlich auch noch ausbauen, weil es gibt ja auch äh quasi standardisierte PCR-Tests äh äh Signaturen und so weiter, ne. Soweit äh die Idee. So. Ähm.
Diese Möglichkeit, das zu unterstützen, ist jetzt mit dem neuen Update in der Corona-Warn-App schon drin.
Allein es gibt noch keinen zertifizierten Anbieter eines solchen Veliation Service.
Es gibt allerdings ein Unternehmen, das
schon einen gebaut hat und von dem das BMG angekündigt hat, dass dieses Unternehmen einen Validation Service bereitstellen wird
auch wenn das BMG diesen Service noch nicht abgenommen und freigegeben hat und dieses Unternehmen ist.
Die auch die Corona-Warn-App bauen im Auftrag des BMG.
Also nicht genau die App, sondern die Backend-Infrastruktur vor allem machen.
Aber die an dem Projekt beteiligt sind, so. Und dieser Validation Service wird.
Äh B2B angeboten. Also wird dann anderen ähm Unternehmen, die jetzt beispielsweise einer Airline, die Interesse daran hat, diese Funktion zu benutzen, letztendlich halt eine API bereitstellen, das ganze Asso-Service.
Verkaufen. Das heißt ausgerechnet T-Sistance hat jetzt einen zweiten Business Case außerhalb der Corona-Warn-App in Richtung von.
Ja in in Richtung von B to B angeboten. Noch dazu,
wird hier jetzt eben, was also was ist dieser Service? Man kann jetzt auch an der,
Architektur ja man kann dadran rummeckern, man kann auch sagen es gibt viele andere Möglichkeiten das gleiche Ziel zu erreichen ja ohne einen äh zentralen Veliation Server,
Ja? Ähm die wurden hier aber nicht gebaut und ich glaube auch nicht, dass die das eigentliche Problem.
Lösen würden. Also weil,
ich interpretiere, dass ihr das das große Problem ist quasi die Rechtssicherheit, ja? Also diese Validation Service
den schreibe ich dir an einem Tag in Python, ne? Das ist wirklich jetzt nicht das Problem. Die ganzen Librarys zur Prüfung von Impfzertifikaten gibt's ja. Äh die ähm
äh Ruolsets musst du dann da reinlehnen, musst laden musst dich vielleicht noch ein bisschen mit Revocation auseinandersetzen, bisschen Management drumherum. Der technische Teil ist nicht das Problem.
Den aber immer aktuell zu halten.
Und auch auf Änderungen dynamisch reagieren zu können und den in einer Weise zu betreiben, dass du ihn als Dienstleistung anderen gegenüber mit potentieller,
Verfügbarkeits ähm Garantie und ähm Haftung für Fehler,
Nichtverfügbarkeit bereitstellen kannst. Da ist natürlich die Musik drin Geld zu verdienen.
Es könnte unter Umständen noch weitere, ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz so sicher, wie das jetzt in der ersten Phase ist, aber in diesem ganzen Zusammenspiel gehört ja zum Beispiel auch die Überprüfung im Kontext eines Ausweisdokuments noch mit dazu. Das kann also sehr wohl sein, dass sich
dieser ganze Vorgang an der Stelle noch etwas komplexer darstellt, entweder mit Unterlagen, die vorhin dem, in dem Fall halt dem Flug
Unternehmen äh kommen oder eben die noch äh von anderer Seite von dem
User geliefert werden muss. Ich erinnere an diese ganzen Verification-Dienste, die es ja heute schon gibt, um so Accounts zu öffnen oder postedent und all diese ganzen äh Sachen kann kann kann sehr wohl sein, dass das dann halt auch noch Teil der Überprüfung wird und weit mehr ist als jetzt nur ein QR-Code zu scannen.
Da hast du eine schöne Idee. Ich denke allerdings also du wirst eine Sache nicht rauskriegen aus diesem ganzen Prozess, egal was du machst. Du musst an,
bleiben wir beim Flugzeug. Du musst beim Boarding feststellen, dass das auch wirklich die Person ist. Also selbst wenn du schon vorher,
den äh Impfpass hast und wenn du jetzt was vielleicht,
klug klingt, aber eigentlich keinen Mehrwert bietet, sogar noch einen Posten machst, oder ein Video-Edent oder was auch immer, ja? Da muss in dem Moment, wo du den Einlass regelst, wirst du den Ausweis kontrollieren müssen.
Und.
Da sind wir jetzt wieder auch bei dem tatsächlichen Aspekt. Wenn du das trotzdem ohnehin noch tun musst, dann ist dieser gesamte Effizienzgewinn natürlich auch um einiges geringer.
Ja, weil du musst trotzdem, ne, dein dein Check-in-Prozess, wo du jetzt gerade ergänzt, um Ausweis zeigen, ja. Ähm,
klar, Impfpass könntest du jetzt potenziell äh dann aus dieser,
Gleichung rausnehmen, also ein Drittel deiner Überprüfungsaufgaben entfällt. Normalerweise musst du, was weiß ich, Ticket äh Impfpassausweis, ja? Das könntest du jetzt äh reduzieren auf Ticket und ähm Ausweis.
Gut, aber es geht ja auch dadrum, sowas im Vorfeld schon zu checken, damit das eben gar nicht erst noch zusätzlich mit dazukommt. Äh und der Prozess bleibt halt so, wie er immer ist.
Was du sagen möchtest ist, es geht darum, dass sie den Menschen die Situation ersparen, dass sie irgendwo am Flughafen stehen und ähm,
ja verärgert sind. Und es geht darum äh Prozess äh Einlass natürlich schneller äh zu ähm ermöglichen. Aber Ziel schneller zu ermöglichen. Du hast weiterhin das Problem der äh der Ausweiskontrolle.
Daran anschließend.
Kommt jetzt mein entscheidender Punkt. Dieses Business-Modell wird natürlich nicht nur einer Airline angeboten werden, die.
In gewisser Form.
Keinen größeren Schaden anrichtet, dadurch, dass sie ein solches Feature umsetzt, weil sie ohnehin die Person namentlich ähm erfasst hat und quasi ähm,
ja nicht nicht viel mehr Schaden macht, außer, dass sie das hier, dass sie jetzt nochmal alle Kunden durch einen zentralen oder einen von wenigen zentralen Anbietern durchpeipt,
der dann von allen, die dort buchen, auch weiß, dass sie's tun. Ja, dass äh der Kritikpunkt an dieser zentralen Architektur. In meinen Augen beginnt das Problem dann, wenn andere Anbieterinnen.
Diese Funktionalität übernehmen, die zum heutigen Zeitpunkt noch keine namentliches Ticketing haben. Also, Konzert.
Fußball. Tim Fußball kennst du, ne? Interessiert dich.
Haben aber namentliches Ticketing.
Werder Bremen, was du da immer guckst, ne? Und ähm.
Die haben aber namentliches Ticketing.
Ja bei bei deinen Dauerkarten ein normaler Hooligan, ein normaler Hooligan kann sich immer noch ein Ticket am am am U-Bahnhof beim Schwarzhändler kaufen.
In den letzten zwei Jahren nicht. Corona alles komplett immer.
Zwei Jahren nicht, ist ja genau der Punkt. Da da genau darüber rede ich ja jetzt gerade so. Wir haben äh wir führen jetzt
mit diesem Feature potenziell äh namentliches äh Ticketing ein und es gibt eine ganze Menge Leute, die da durchaus auch daran Interesse haben.
Ja gut, aber das namentliche Ticketing haben wir schon. Also es wird jetzt nicht durch dieses Feature äh ermöglicht, sondern das ist ja sozusagen jetzt schon da.
Wird aber dadurch zementiert.
Ja, gut, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht.
Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe äh Veranstaltungen also.
Es gibt eine ganze Reihe Veranstaltungen, da gibt es kein namentliches Ticketing. Klar, äh beim Fußball, da will ich auch wo wo die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Rechtsradikalen, Gewaltverbrecher irgendwie äh hingehen.
Dich. Nenn mir mal ein Beispiel. Also ich kenne jetzt gar keine einzige Veranstaltung in den letzten zwei Jahren, wo nicht namentliches Ticketing war.
Spreche gerade äh spezifisch davon, du hast gesagt, in zwei Monaten ist die Pandemie vorbei.
Wenn die Pandemie vorbei ist, brauchen wir auch die Überprüfung dieser Zertifikate nicht mehr.
Aber du wirst das namentliche Ticketing nicht mehr los, was du jetzt damit ausrollst.
So, weiß nicht.
Inklusive Ausweiskontrolle am Einlass. Also das ist keine gute Idee. Das ist keine also um's kurz zusammenzufassen. Namentliches Ticketing.
In den Bereichen, wo es vor der Pandemie und in zwei Monaten, wenn die Themen in Übereinstimmung wenn die wenn die Pandemie in der übereinstehenden.
Wenn die Pandemie in Übereinstimmung mit Tims Prophezeiung dann vorbei ist, dann wird man's hoffentlich auch nicht mehr brauchen. Aber.
Denke nicht, dass das etwas ist, wo man sich ohne ähm Not reindrängen sollte, nur um irgendwie potenziell hier diesen äh Check-In-Vorgang äh etwas zu vereinfachen.
Ja gut, also ich ich teile deine deine Bewertung nur nur,
teilweise, weil ähm das Problem mit haben wir eine Verpflichtung zu namentlicher Bestellung und Teilnahme an Veranstaltungen oder können die anonym stattfinden, wie sie's vorher gemacht haben. Ist so das eine. In diesem Fall ist dieser Dienst ja sozusagen
äh nicht der Schalter, der das ein oder ausschaltet, sondern der ja nur die Überprüfung dieser Corona-Zertifikate
extern macht, die sonst halt von dem Dienst äh selbst gemacht werden müssten. Also ich sehe da jetzt diesen unmittelbaren Zusammenhang
äh nicht so klar.
Ja, okay, dann hast du deinen Punkt gebracht. Ich habe ihn jetzt auch gebracht, ja. Ähm ich denke,
dass äh es dass es hier mehrere Forderungen ergeben.
Erstens und jetzt erstmal unabhängig von der Architektur. Dass Feature darf nicht verpflichtend sein. Du musst auch einfach sagen können, ich möchte,
was weiß ich daran nicht teilnehmen und bestehe auf einer äh Impfmaßkontrolle am Einlass,
Und zweitens, wer heute keine namentliche Erfassung hat oder vor zwei Jahren keine hatte
sollte sie jetzt nicht einführen beziehungsweise in den zwei Monaten
äh die du der Pandemie noch gibst, dann auch äh wieder absetzen. Ja, das ist schon ein äh genereller Gewinn,
dass wir äh die meisten Orte betreten können ohne ähm Ausweis.
Erfassung und es macht einen entscheidenden Unterschied, dass ich heute von mir aus an irgendeinem Restaurant jemandem,
solange ich nicht an irgendeinen Kölner Wirt gelange, jemanden kurz nachweise, dass ich geimpft bin.
Dieses Restaurant aber nicht speichert, äh wer ich bin und dass ich da war. Ja, also ich ich reserviere meinen Tisch auf Mickey Mouse,
gehe hin, zeige mein äh Linus Neumann im Impfausweis und mein äh Personalausweis. Ähm und bin aber jetzt nicht dort erfasst.
Mickey Mouse, du bist das. Habe ich doch schon öfter gesehen in der Liste. Jetzt jetzt weiß ich endlich mal, wer da.
Luca ruft auch andauernd an. Nein und äh das ist ein Unterschied. Ja und das ist ein entscheidender Unterschied, ob diese namentliche Erfassung stattfindet.
Oder,
ob äh du ob die ob eine Prüfung des Impfstatus stattfindet und das ist äh ja das ist ein entscheidender Unterschied. Das ist äh ein ähm ja ein fundamentale Änderung dessen, wie das hier,
passiert.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, dieser Dienst lagert ja im Prinzip nur die Überprüfung aus.
Nein, das ist ja sorry Tim, das ist ja genau das, das ist ja genau mein Argument. Der lagert nur die äh Überprüfung aus und du, der den Dienst nutzt, musst am Ende den Ausweis am Einlass kontrollieren, also musst du namentlich erfassen, wer kommt.
Das musstest du vorher nicht, wenn du den Dienst nicht nutzt und sagst, ich mache ein äh Musikfestival.
So, du du befürchtest jetzt sozusagen eine generelle Verpflichtung, dass man den in allen Fällen immer benutzen muss. So habe ich das nicht verstanden, sondern.
Nee, du musst mir schon zuhören. Ich habe gesagt, also erstens ja, natürlich.
Ich muss dir jetzt auch noch zuhören. Was was was bringt dieses Jahr denn noch an äh Verschlimmbesserungen?
So läuft das hier. Also, ich habe spezifisch hergesagt, also ich habe gerade gesagt, bei einer Airline sehe ich kein Problem, weil die Airline ohnehin dein.
Sowieso machen muss. Okay, gut, alles klar. Jetzt habe ich seinen Punkt auch verstanden.
Deswegen habe ich das mit der Airline die ganze Zeit durchgesprochen.
Okay du Fuchs.
Die Airline erfasst ohnehin Länder, PNR und so weiter, ja? Die Airline hat außerdem potentiell wechselnde Routets und so weiter.
Das heißt, bei der Airline kannst du das verstehen. Für eine Airline ändert sich durch das, was jetzt passiert, dass es,
Dass Sie Geld an einen Till system Service bezahlen kann, wenn Sie das möchte,
Und dieser T-System Service ähm potenziell würde ich jetzt mal schätzen, dass IBM Ubid äh hier nichts senio oder irgendjemand wird so was vielleicht auch noch anbieten, aber besonders viele Konkurrenten wird's da nicht geben.
Wollen wir nicht mitmachen.
Nee ähm so äh dieser Service weiß aber dann zum Beispiel ne oder kann wissen, äh was weiß ich, Tim hat sich grade gegenüber der Ryanair oder mit wem du fliegst. Ähm.
Bestimmt nicht. Das kann ich dir versichern. Also ich äh wenn ich wenn ich die Möglichkeit habe und ich habe sie meistens ja, dann verzichte ich immer auf Ryanair.
So hat sich gegenüber hier Etihad äh ausgewiesen. Ähm und ne, du hättest du hast also jetzt.
Willst du damit sagen, dass ich immer Luxusklasse fliege oder was?
Etat ist, naja weiß ich nicht, das ist ein Air-Berlin-Verschnitt, oder? Na ja, jedenfalls die ähm du du hast jetzt einen weiteren Service, wo potenziell zentralisiert,
Daten anfallen, ja? Oder wenn wenn man jetzt sagt, na ja, es gibt ja mehrere Services, da hast du trotzdem keine freie Wahl, weil ja der,
Der Anbieter, wo du dann dein Ticket buchst
diese Wahl trifft und T-Systems hat eben hier jetzt sicherlich einen nennenswerten Marktvorteil, ja.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Ist mir dann aber auch egal.
So und.
Jetzt frag, jetzt kommt denn der nächste Punkt, ja? Also nur mal so das Ausmaß dieser ganzen Sache mal darzustellen.
Einen neuen Gesundheitsminister und ähm der alte Gesundheitsminister hieß ja Spahn und der Herr Spahn war in der CDU und die CDU ist ja so eine.
So eine Bromi-Partei, ja, das heißt, der hat sich natürlich da äh seine Leute, seine treuen CDU-Homies äh reingeholt
und das für die Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen zuständig und damit auch für die Corona-Warn-App war Gottfried Ludewig.
Der früher mal äh Vorsitzender der Jungen Union war.
Und dieser Gottfried Ludewig ist jetzt natürlich im BMG unter äh Lauterbach besetzt seine äh Besetzte, wahrscheinlich jetzt, sage ich mal, die zentralen Stellen, die ja mit kompetenten Leuten und deswegen musste der Ludewick jetzt wahrscheinlich gehen,
und der arbeitet aber jetzt der hat jetzt einen Job bei in genau diesem Gesundheitsding. Das heißt.
Überraschung.
Ludewig wird jetzt mehr oder weniger bei den Leuten arbeiten, die mit Remote-Veditation einen B2B-Service-modell äh auf Basis der,
bis dahin immer hochgelobten Corona-Warn-App haben. So, ich verstehe nicht, warum man einen solchen,
Rufschaden an diesem Projekt ähm riskieren muss, ja ähm.
Ich glaube, wie gesagt, es gibt Vorschläge, man kann das auch ohne Einigation Service machen. Du kannst ja irgendwie sagen, keine Ahnung ähm.
Sowas wie du prüfst den QR-Code, also dir wird ein QR-Code mit einem Ruleset gegeben. Die Corona-Warn-App checkt, ob du gegen dieses ob du diesen Ruleset entsprichst. Das ist eine Funktion, die hat sie schon. Du kannst heute deinen ähm,
Also wenn du heute sagst, ich möchte meine äh Gültigkeit für eine Reise prüfen, dann wird letztendlich einfach nur das aktuelle des Zielortes genommen, ja? Das heißt, der Code ist schon da, gegen Ruleset prüfen. Der ist in der Corona-Warn-App drin.
Und du könntest quasi auch einfach ein System bauen, in dem du jetzt quasi, in dem die Airline sagt, hier ist dein Ruleset, scann das mal, QR Code in der Corona-Warn-App. Dann sagt die Corona-Warn-App, alles klar, das ist eine für eine Reise da und da hin. Du entsprichst dem,
und dann könntest du noch in den QR-Code irgendeinen,
ähm irgendeinen ähm random Quarterback mit reinnehmen, wo die Corona-Warn-App, den die dann aufruft und sagt, jo übrigens, ich habe geprüft, Person, die Person, die jetzt grade gescannt hat,
entspricht diesem ja? Und dann hättest du diesen Teil gelöst ohne einen zentralen Velitation Service. Problem,
wenn da irgendetwas schiefgeht und sich die Regeln ändern, weißt du halt nicht, was du machen sollst. Aber man kann.
Ein solches Feature auch bauen ohne dass dabei ein Business Case entsteht für,
Services. Das ist äh ein Fakt.
Kann man natürlich sagen, okay, wenn du den QR-Code selber äh dekodierst, könntest du diesen Endpunkt auch einfach aufrufen und damit könntest du quasi, ne.
Fälschen, dass du einen Impfpass hast, der wir dabei eh am Eingang nochmal kontrolliert. So, wäre jetzt eine Möglichkeit, das Ganze ähm dezentral zu bauen.
Die hätte und das glaube ich ist der andere Punkt net was die Leute haben wollen ist Rechtssicherheit die hätte es in diesem Fall nicht.
Wäre also hier theoretisch möglich, dass du äh ja lieber dein äh Impfausweis äh lügst.
Grundsätzlich würde ich sagen, dass wir das überhaupt brauchen,
Dass man da jetzt einen Velidation Service braucht, liegt eigentlich daran, dass man nicht mit dem Impfzertifikat den Leuten einfach auch ein Secret gegeben hat, ja? Kriegst du jetzt nicht mehr ausgerollt, aber du könntest ja theoretisch einfach auch ähm ein Secret-Key haben, mit dem du Sachen signierst
Ja und dann signierst du eben, dass du einem äh Woolset entsprichst,
haben wir hier diese Sache mit dem Service und der stinkt einfach, ne? Also namentliche Registrierung wird ermutigt. Wie gesagt, da wo sie ohnehin schon stattfindet, entsteht kein größerer Schaden, da wo sie noch nicht stattfindet. Lecken sich die Leute jetzt die Finger.
Und sagen.
Zu meinem Festival könnte ich immer namentliche Erfassungen machen, weil vielleicht möchte ich ja einfach den Schwarzmarkt versuchen trocken zu legen.
Zweitens ähm ich spare mir Zeit am Einlass, also sammle ich mal eben von allen Leuten äh die.
Namen nach Personalausweis und macht die Welle macht die äh Impfpass-Verifizierung über so einen Service. Alle
happy, weil ähm ja Einlasspotentiell ein bisschen schneller geht. Tickets im äh Zweitmarkt nicht so teuer werden.
Und äh alles gut. Das heißt, hier entsteht jetzt ein großer Incentive für namentliches Ticketing und namentliches Ticketing ist, sage ich mal, nicht,
im Interesse der Besucherinnen und Besucher. Und diese Drehtür mit dem Judeweg, Mann ey. Aber okay, Gottfried Ludewig hat.
Das noch groß auf? Also ich meine, das ist ähm.
Ist halt so.
Ich find's halt schon ich habe ähm diese die Corona-Warn-App hat verdient.
'ne ganze Menge Vorschussvertrauen bekommen als sie gelauncht ist ja und.
Sie ist äh ne dezentral anonym und schnell. Sie ist eine elegante Lösung mit dem
Exposian-Notivation Framework. Sie hat sehr viele Vorteile. Sie hat dann sogar noch äh angelehnt an Crowd Notifire, den die schnelle Notification für Orte,
eingebaut, allerdings zu spät, ja es stand es entstand diese Marktlücke, in die dann die Luca App gesprungen ist, aber die Corona-Warn-App hat auch hier,
überlegene Lösung und jetzt so am Ende kommt auf einmal so ein Ding rum, ja? Und jetzt musst du äh äh dir halt überlegen wie geht man damit um? Deswegen also ich kann nur sagen
ich also ich verstehe dieses Feature wird kommen.
Das wirst du jetzt nicht mehr. Also dafür ist der Bedarf allein auf Seiten der Airlines groß genug und auch der Bedarf von T-Systems noch weiter Geld zu verdienen, ja. Ähm
wann wird's da nicht mehr rauskriegen?
Aus der äh Corona-Warn-App und wenn, dann wird's halt in die Luca App eingebaut und die freuen sich. Ja, also haste nix von. Also es wird Remote Veliation geben. Es wird ein Geschäftsmodell sein. Ähm.
Insofern denke ich, kann man jetzt nur,
Schadensbegrenzung machen, indem man wie gesagt fordert OK erstens du kannst die Leute nicht dazu verpflichten, die müssen Anspruch haben auf äh Impfpasskontrolle an Ort und Stelle. Der Ausweis muss sowieso immer noch kontrolliert werden, insofern ist das jetzt auch nicht so tragisch.
Und zweitens, diejenigen, die vor zwei Jahren noch keine namentliche Registrierung hatten, äh sollten diese jetzt auch nicht deswegen einführen.
Weil,
ne? Kommt irgendwann jemand vorbei, holt euch die Daten da raus und das ist einfach uncool, ja? Und das sind auch die Dinge, vor denen ja äh zu Recht,
gewarnt wurde,
mit den ganzen Impffesten und so, dass gesagt wurde, ey dann wird man überall muss man seinen Ausweis zeigen, wird kontrolliert und so weiter, ja und dass das damit eine Überwachung,
entstehen kann. Ja oder also Überwachung im Sinne von große, zentrale Datensammlungen, unklarer Provenienz. Und ähm.
Genau das passiert jetzt, ja? Noch dazu, also dass sich T-Systems da jetzt ein Business-Model raus spinnt aus der aus der Corona-Warn-App.
Einfach nicht schön, ja. Also da wird einfach dieses Vorschussvertrauen ähm enttäuscht und jetzt kommt's, jetzt liest du, ich habe ja wie gesagt, wir sprechen ja über diese Sache Contact Racing wird ein ddemisch, jetzt liest du nämlich äh die Verträge,
für die Corona-Warnapp wurden jetzt ähm verlängert. Ja Bundesgesundheitsministerium hat den
laufenden Vertrag mit Telekom und SAP ähm.
Bis zum 31. Dezember 222 verlängert. Äh kostet nochmal 25 Millionen Euro. Ähm,
kurz vor der Bundestagswahl haben Sie diese Verlängerungsoption äh gezogen und ähm.
Dann wird hier im im Spiegel zitiert ähm dass man sich quasi ähm,
darüber Gedanken macht, wie man äh nach Omikron und nach der Pandemie mit der Corona-Warn-App weitermacht.
Äh die Corona-Warnapp soll, wenn es nach ihnen geht, überleben, sie sei die erfolgreichste öffentliche App aller Zeiten, mit dutzenden Steuermillionen entwickelt und deshalb viel zu schade,
fürs Museum der Kommunikation. Äh ich zitiere aus dem Spiegelartikel,
bereits Ideen für ein zweites Leben, etwa als Bundeswarnapp für den Katastrophenschutz in der bestehende Lösung, wie Katwan und Nina aufgehen könnten, eine andere Idee. Die Warn-App könnte zur Gesundheitsamt werden und dann etwa E-Rezepte bei Apotheken,
eingelöst werden, ja? Eigentlich sollte das schon seit Jahresbeginn flächendeckend möglich sein, aber ja E-Rezept haben sie auch wieder verkackt. Ja, das heißt, jetzt sitzen sie da,
haben ne anfangs haben sie hier keine kommerzielle Nutzung dezentral Daten, sondern so weiter, alles schön erfüllt und jetzt,
kommen natürlich die Begehrlichkeiten, dass man denkt, meine Güte, wir haben hier halt eine Installationsbasis von 40 Millionen. Das wäre doch schade, wenn wir da nicht noch äh weiteres Geld mit verdienen und das ist einfach enttäuschend.
Na ja, okay, lassen wir die beiden Sachen mal auseinanderhalten. Also das eine ist die Weiterentwicklung als äh App. Das andere ist diese Sache mit Warn und Katastrophen so. Also in dem Katastrophenteil,
gehe ich sogar mit. Ja, also das macht Sinn, weil derzeit haben wir da einen totalen Wildwuchs und die anderen Apps sind alle furchtbar.
Also
Ja, die mögen oder der ein oder anderen Nutzen gezeigt haben, aber im im Wesentlichen kann man det auch alles mal wegwerfen und neu machen und die Installationsbasis mag zwar gegeben sein, aber die ist halt nicht besonders groß. Und dass sie äh an der Stelle jetzt überlegen, okay, selbst wenn
Apple, das Contact Tracing, Framework äh schließen wird und Google, ne, was ja angekündigt haben, wenn Pandemie vorbei ist, also in zwei Monaten, ne, weißt du, ähm,
dann äh schalten wir das auch ab betriebssystemseitig und dann würde ja quasi diese Funktion entfallen.
Ähm und dann könnte man ja mit mit der App im Prinzip dann müsste man sie ja nicht komplett einstellen.
Ne, also man könnte ja dann sagen, okay wir nehmen das Feature raus, wird ja dann eh abgeschaltet äh und wir machen aber jetzt was anderes damit. Und wir verwenden das jetzt generell als Warn,
App, für Pandemien und sonstige Bedrohungen der Gesellschaft. Habe ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt gar kein Problem damit. Inwiefern das Ding dann auch als,
Gesundheitswerkzeug funktionieren kann oder sollte. Tja, das
äh hängt natürlich dann sehr davon ab in in in was sie das dann
mutieren wollen. Wenn sie letzten Endes hier einen Pfad einschlagen wollen, der diese ganzen Designprinzipien und Grundansätze der Corona-Warn-App halt auch für eine öffentliche Infrastru,
und auch für eine Gesundheitsinfrastruktur weiterentwickelt, würde ich mich dem jetzt gedanklich erstmal auch nicht unbedingt äh verschließen, auch wenn ich mir das doch noch mal genauer anschauen wollen würde, was sie denn dann da tun, ne. Also das Ding kann natürlich dann jetzt nicht
der persönliche Datenspeicher werden, aber es könnte dann äh natürlich unter Umständen ein Abwicklungswerkzeug werden.
So ist eben nicht selber Daten über mich groß speichert.
In einem Maße, was jetzt irgendwie über diese persönliche Speicherung, die sie ja heute schon macht, in Form dieser Zertifikate äh hinausgeht.
Ja, aber äh das sind ja jetzt äh also da die Dinge, die du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, klar, du hast sie getrennt und man glaube, wir sind uns aber auch darüber einig, dass die Zeichen gerade nicht wirklich in diese Richtung stehen, ja? Dass äh,
dass die dies die Prinzipien werden ja jetzt bereits mit dieser Nutzung von Services äh verletzt oder äh stark in Frage gestellt und ähm ich würde vielleicht an dieser Stelle,
Ähm wie gesagt, ich habe ja bereits gesagt, der Punkt ist das ist.
Das Problem in meinen Augen ist nicht unbedingt diese Remote-Velitation. Ja, die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass ähm zum Beispiel der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte Ulrich Kälber noch dafür sorgt, dass es entsprechend äh strenge Auflagen für diese Vediation Services gibt.
Ähm ist relativ hoch und das jetzt diese Validation Services ausgerechnet,
das fette Daten-Leak werden, was der Corona-Warn-App zum Verhängnis wird, wo man dann sieht, wo das Tim doch,
fliegt. Äh Ryanair, obwohl das ist auch Ryanair ist echt eine Klasse für sich. Aber ähm dann äh äh dass diese Daten verloren gehen, halte ich auch für verhältnismäßig gering, ja.
Ähm insofern sage ich mal so gewissermaßen ist es ein äh.
Es ist jetzt nix wo wo ich groß gegen Aufbegehren würde,
aber das, was hier passiert und das ist genau der äh äh dieses Phänomen nennt sich Feature Creep, ja,
kriechen da jetzt langsam weitere Features rein. Und da haben wir einen Valeation Service und hier, jetzt kannst du irgendwann äh direkt drüber buchen. Diese Dinge
ja? Die und das war auch tatsächlich in den Presseanfragen, die es zu dem Thema bekommen habe. Die Sachen, die man vermeiden wollte,
Indem man sagt nein, wir machen das hier. Das ist eine App der öffentlichen Hand, die gehorcht nicht kommerziellen Interessen, sondern pandemischer Notwendigkeit.
Und äh äh die die die lösten Problem gezielt und elegant und nicht einfach durch irgendeine Plumpe zentrale äh Datensammlung, ja? Und es waren mehrere Journalisten,
mich im Prinzip angeschrieben haben und gesagt haben, pass mal auf Norman, das war doch eigentlich das, wovor ihr bei der Luca-App die ganze Zeit Angst hatten.
Sie sich da irgendwie andere Business Cases dran zimmern. Und das passiert nun mal hier.
Dann eben damit quasi hier Wallet für alle einfacher ist, kontrollier doch einfach am Einlass nur noch den Personalausweis.
Das sind einfach keine positiven Entwicklungen. Und die sind wie gesagt es ist jetzt nicht der schlimme Dammbruch, aber irgendwann, wenn man sagt, wo war der Punkt, wo es angefangen hat schief zu gehen? Da wird es genau der gewesen sein.
Also,
okay, also ich äh akzeptiere, dass du das äh äh da warnend so siehst. Sicherlich muss man da genau anschauen. Mir äh fehlt hier noch so ein bisschen das Empörungspotential, einfach aus dem Grund heraus,
weil ich diesen Validierungsdienst an sich für eine sinnvolle Sache halte, weil
grade diese ganze kritische Überprüfung und so weiter eben nicht bei 1tausend Anbietern von irgendwelchen ähm Veranstaltungsdiensten laufen sollte, sondern das eigentlich sehr gut ist, wenn das da nicht ist, ne.
Da hast du einen guten Punkt. Das muss man nochmal spezifisch anerkennen. Würde man es nicht so machen, sondern stattdessen die Daten irgendwo zentral sammeln.
Ja, dann hättest du im Zweifelsfall, also da wirst du am Ende der Pandemie, also in zwei Monaten, mehr,
Datenlecks haben als mit diesem einen zentralen Veliation Service, der einmal richtig durchgeputzt wird und unter starken.
Nur stattfindet und so weiter, ne? Und es ist ein Standard und äh ist jetzt sozusagen auch nicht so, dass jetzt nur die Telekom das machen kann, sondern andere können das halt auch machen. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das jetzt ehrlich gesagt so eine große Goldgrube ist so, sondern das ist für die halt eher
Teil einer äh Gesamteicht
wo sie halt überall präsent sein wollen, weil halt Gesundheit für sie ein wichtiger Bereich ist. Ich meine, da gibt's ja auch viel zu digitalisieren. Packen wir's an. Also ich meine, das beklagen wir ja äh auch nachhaltig, dass dass es hier nicht äh vorangeht, sollen die sich da gerne engagieren, solange sie es richtig machen.
Was ich noch sagen möchte ist, klar Feature-Creep kann ein Problem sein äh,
Dinge können, können jetzt auch falsch laufen bei der Corona-Wahl. Können, können aber auch.
Anders laufen. Und im Prinzip sehe ich's halt hier so ein bisschen mehr als Chance ähm darauf zu drängen, zu sagen
erstmal man sollte diese App konkret,
so weiterentwickeln, dass, sagen wir mal, wenn jetzt Pandemie-Ende ist und nächstes Jahr kommt dann das nächste Virus und man stellt fest, oh, jetzt müssen wir das aber wieder anschalten.
Ja? Dass die App nicht sofort gleich hinten raus purzelt äh aus dem App Store, weil in der Zwischenzeit Sachen reingekommen sind, für die
andere Updates, entsprechende Apps ja abgelehnt wurden. Also es gab ja das in UK zum Beispiel, wo sie tatsächlich so einen zentralen Speicher äh Ding sie äh rankoppeln wollten. Ich
sind ja hundert Prozent zusammen was es war, aber dann ist das Update halt von Apple irgendwie und Google glaube ich auch einfach abgelehnt worden so nach dem Motto Leute ihr habt ja euch die Bedingungen nicht,
gelesen. So äh kommt ihr hier nicht rein, ne. Das heißt, die die App dürfte, wenn sie denn überhaupt wieder in diese Verwendung dieses Exposione-Notification-Framwork reinrutscht, was ja jederzeit passieren könnte.
Ähm dürfte sie sich eben entsprechend auch gar nicht entwickeln und das ist schon mal ein relativ starkes Argument. Und davon abgesehen.
Von diesem Detail des Konflikts mit dem äh App Store, die ist uns potenziellen Konflikts mit dem App Store in der Zukunft
denke ich auch, dass wir jetzt einen schönen Showcase gehabt haben mit der Corona-Warn-App so nach dem Motto, gucke mal, man kann das halt auch alles mal anders,
als es bisher gelaufen ist, weil im Vergleich zu dem wie Infrastrukturprojekte gerade im Gesundheitsbereich aber nicht nur dort,
wir ja oft genug äh zerfleddert. Ähm haben einfach nicht diesen Grad an Transparenz gehabt. Haben nicht diesen Open Source äh teil gehabt, ja. Gut, das äh mag nicht alles von Anfang an funktioniert haben. Trotzdem war die Entwicklung dieser App
ein sehr unterhaltsamer vergleichsweise transparenter Vorgang
Wo man wirklich auch im Zweifelsfall wirklich mal auf GitHub gucken konnte, wie's denn wirklich läuft und ähm das muss eben so als Vorbild auch äh weiterentwickelt werden und ich denke, da steht die Regierung auch unter Druck, das so zu machen.
Hier genau wieder nicht der Fall.
Wieso? Gibt doch einen Standard.
Dieses Feature, dieses spezifische Feature wurde dir wurde die Weltöffentlichkeit drüber informiert mit äh mit dem bereit äh Stellen der Dingens. Das ist genau nicht, dass es vorher diskutiert wurde.
Gut, ich weiß jetzt nicht ehrlich gesagt, wie viele es auf europäischer Ebene diskutiert wurde, ähm kann ich nicht beurteilen. So, aber es ist ja klar definiert, wie es zu funktionieren hat. Also es gibt ja da ein eine Protokollspezifikation.
Ja und die wer hat sich die dahin geschrieben?
Der hat ja geschrieben. Es ist es ist du willst drehst und wendest. Von von diesen Prinzipien wird da jetzt grade Abstand genommen.
Und deswegen markiere ich das ja. Ich sage ja wie gesagt, dieses Feature wird kommen. Ich halte es für unwahrscheinlich, dass da jetzt das große Datenleck entsteht
Ich würde sagen, man wird es nicht verpflichtend machen können oder man sollte es nicht verpflichtend machen und man sollte Anbieterinnen, die keine äh namentliche Erfassung haben, auch nicht unbedingt dazu raten, das jetzt einzuführen.
Einfach nur, weil es gesellschaftlich das falsche Signal ist und zweitens, weil sie im Zweifelsfall auch mit den Namen
schon überfordert sind, die sicher äh aufzubewahren und äh die Prinzipien, die du da benennst, die werden gerade verletzt,
Gleichzeitig halte ich es für unwahrscheinlich, dass wir dieses Feature stoppen kann oder stoppen wird.
Und auch würde sogar sagen, da gibt's ja dann so diesen Aspekt, ne, Wirtschaftlichkeit und so weiter
es gibt einfach viele Leute, die das haben wollen und zwar auf Anbieterseite und äh auch auf Kundenseite. Wenn du dir die Leute anguckst am Flughafen
weißt du Bescheid.
Okay Leo, du bist jetzt wieder auf diesen Service gegangen. Meine Argumentation, die mit der ich gerade begonnen hatte, bezog sich jetzt mehr auf diesen Aspekt
wie soll diese App weiterentwickelt werden? In was soll diese App sich künftig unter Umständen weiterentwickel,
Ja, das das war jetzt so eigentlich meine meine Stoßrichtung in dieser Argumentation und ähm das muss man beobachten jetzt. Also ich ähm bin gespannt, aber ich denke halt auch äh jetzt haben wir da schon relativ viel Energie reingesteckt,
Im Prinzip ist das alles in der Summe ein sehr positives Ergebnis. Das kann man glaube ich nicht von der Hand weisen und ähm das,
muss jetzt, daran muss jetzt gearbeitet werden, dass dass das jetzt so ein akzeptierter way of doings wird. Dass dass diese Prinzipien beibehalten werden.
Genau der Satz, den du gerade gesagt hast, der ist äh bei Nexenio auch gefallen, wo wir jetzt halt zum zweiten Thema äh die Corona-Apps werden in dem ich kommen.
Auch eine gute Nachricht.
Du bist jetzt wieder über die Luca-App reden?
Es gibt ein eine sehr interessante Recherche von Netzpolitik ORG, die wir hier selbstverständlich würdigen müssen. Ähm und zwar,
äh hoffentlich nicht so lang, weil einfach mal weniger Widerworte gibst, dann könnten wir die Themen auch einfach schneller.
Was fällt mir ein? Ja, eine eigene Meinung zu entwickeln. In meinem Podcast. Frechheit.
Erzähl mal. Ich will eh nicht über Luca App reden.
Ich habe ja schon gesagt, äh äh Luca App äh Vertragsverlängerung steht an.
Steht gar nicht an, die haben eine Abo-Falle in ihren Verträgen. Ähm das heißt, die Kündigungsfrist läuft bald ab und die Länder müssen jetzt äh die Verträge aktiv kündigen, sonst müssen sie nochmal bezahlen.
Ähm ne pfiffig, ne? Und ähm.
Was ich ja auch schon mal erwähnt habe, äh nexenio sagt, sie hätten äh auch um die dreißig, vierzig Millionen Installationen der Luca App.
Und wenn man sich mal überlegt,
welche App ist überhaupt so viele Millionen mal installiert worden? Da kämen nur noch die Corona-Warn-App und dann kommen so Schwergewichte wie WhatsApp und so, ne, wo also,
Milliarden Unternehmen sehr, sehr lange arbeiten mussten, um äh eine solche Installationsbasis zu bekommen. Wenn man so im Marketingbereich guckt, dann liegt so,
so zwischen 130 und 150 bei Android, bei iPhones noch deutlich mehr. Also kannst du im Prinzip sagen, so dieser
das, was die Luca App geschenkt bekommen hat an Installationsbasis dadurch, dass ihre,
Anwendung in 13 Ländern staatlich verordnet wurde und damit ja die Gastronomen gezwungen waren, ihre ähm.
Ihren Kundinnen, die,
Installationen nahe zu legen. Ähm ist also ungefähr so was im Bereich sechzig Millionen Euro, die sie quasi on top,
nochmal geschenkt bekommen haben. Wenn man davon ausgeht, ist es Android. Gehst du mal davon aus, dass auch ein paar iPhone Nutzer die App haben. Dann haben wir jetzt so hundert Millionen.
Euro in Marketing und Installationswert geleistet. Die Gastronominnen für diese App auf Zwang des Staates.
Und da überlegen die sich natürlich auch, ähm.
Was machen Sie in der Anschlussverwendung der App? Und das war übrigens auch, wir haben ja eigentlich als Hitze zehn nur einmal davor gewarnt und haben gesagt, die werden, die suchen nach anderen Geschäftsmodellen und genau das tun Sie jetzt auch grade und interessanterweise steht in diesen LUGA-Verträgen,
Das Recht von Culture for Life, die Software außerhalb des Einsatzgebietes gegebenenfalls nach eigenem Ermessen zu kommen, mezialisieren,
unberührt. Das steht da drin, ja? Die können also jetzt damit machen, was sie wollen, ja? Äh wird kritisiert von Professor Klaus Wendt von der Universität
Siegen. Der sagt, während wichtige Projekte wie die elektronische Gesundheitsakte nicht vorankommen, können Firmen in der Pandemie vorpreschen und der Staat
solchen Apps völlig naiv kaum Einschränkungen.
Ähm das ist natürlich zu kritisieren. Er sagt, der Staat sollte wichtige IT-Infrastrukturen im Gesundheitsbereich selbst in der Hand halten, vertritt er also eine ähnliche Position wie du grade,
zur Corona-Warnapp. Jetzt hatte ich ja schon gesagt, ne, Smudo wirst wieder auf einen Talkshow-Strich und äh stimmt aber gar nicht, denn.
Die haben eine Lobby-Agentur beauftragt. Äh was jetzt hier bei Netzpolitik Org rausgekommen ist und zwar ist das.
Die Lobbyagentur FGH Finsbury Glover haring,
Ähm die für Management im Managermagazin ähm äh,
äh so beschrieben wird als äh der also der Vorstand äh Alexander Geiss wäre der einflussreichste Vorstandsflüsterer Deutschlands.
Nun hat er nur ein, nun hat er ein neues Ziel, FGH zur größten PR-Maschine der Welt zu machen. Ähm,
die machen eher so, also die machen PR, ja, aber ähm wenn man sich mal anschaut, wer da so angestellt ist,
äh würde man eher sagen so Public Affairs, ja, Public Affairs ist ja PR in Richtung der Regierung, ne? Ähm also politische Entscheidungsprozesse Lobbyen.
Und,
In dieser Agentur ist tätig ein Herr mit dem Namen Lutz Stroppe. Und äh dieser Lutz Stroppe war bis vor Kurzem,
Staatssekretär im Gesundheitsministerium und der war einmal der Büroleiter von.
Bundeskanzler Doktor Kohl? Ja? Und der macht jetzt PR und Public Affairs,
für die Luca App.
Bei einer Spin-Doktor-PR-Agentur, die sich anschickt äh oder die plant äh die einflussreichste der Welt zu werden. Ich würde jetzt mal vorsichtig schätzen,
wendet ihr so jemanden kaufst, äh dann ist der nicht ganz so günstig. Ja, wenn er.
Grad fragen, was kostet das.
Staatssekretär, Büroleiter, Kanzler, ja ähm das ist also ich meine, das ist die Drehtür,
par excellence. Er ist vor ein paar äh auch erst vor Kurzem ähm ausm äh Gesundheitsministerium unter unklaren Gründen gegangen. Ähm,
Sag mal.
Vor allem, wenn also in diesem Bereich, in dem der jetzt tätig ist, wird der sicherlich mehr verdienen, als er als Staatssekretär verdient hat, vor allem wenn er mal früher Staatssekretär war. Ja und das ist doch wirklich ich meine.
Je länger du da hinguckst, ne, umso.
Unschöner wird das. Ja, da da hast du jetzt Millionen einem Unternehmen hinterhergeworfen, die jetzt wirklich so die richtig evil Kommunikations-Spin-Doktor Public Affairs-Leute losschicken.
Um äh dich wieder in die Medien zu bringen und da ist irgendwie jemand, der früher Büroleiter des Kanzlers war.
Ist man dann schon automatisch evil eigentlich oder wo Laureus leitest du das jetzt äh ab, dass die Iv.
Also ich würde ehrlich gesagt sagen ähm,
Dann bist du evil. Das also ich ich kann mir ich also wer solchen, wer ich allein.
Also ich ich übrigens nur, damit's nicht wieder heißt, äh ich denke auch, dass T-Systems evil ist und Ludevik Evil ist, dass er jetzt irgendwie äh da jetzt zu denen rübergeht und und an der an der anderen Seite der Corona-Warn-App weiter,
ne? Das ist einfach evil. Das ist macht man nicht.
Wenn jetzt dein Lieblingspolitiker mal Kanzler wird und du wirst dann Kanzler äh Büro lei.
Werde ich ja nicht. Werde ich ja nicht.
Na, das woher weißt du denn das?
Dass ich nicht Kanzlerberater werde? So einen Hungerlohn gehe ich doch nicht arbeiten, Tim.
Ja, dann kannst du auch du kannst doch ganz gut mit Terminen und so. Na ja, also das macht man dann mal ab, wenn's soweit ist.
Die eine Sache, äh die die Sache ist.
Was du danach machst, ja? Wie willst du denn in ein in ein Urteilsvermögen eines äh Staatssekretärs im BMG Vertrauen, wenn der im Nachhinein sein äh Adressbuch,
auf diese Weise äh
äh äh monetarisiert. Und man kann, wenn du den jetzt fragst, dann wird dir der Herr Struppe bestimmt sagen, wie sehr er brennt für die Gesundheitspolitik,
wie wichtig es eben ist mit FGH für die gute Sache zu kämpfen, dass er jetzt irgendwie den Datenschutz aufweichen, um mehr Daten in der Luka App erfassen zu können, ne? Das die können die ja alle immer eine schöne Geschichte erzählen.
Und ich würde, jetzt pass auf, ich glaube die Geschichte sogar, ich glaube auch, dass die alle irgendwie zu Hause sitzen und denken, sie wären hier irgendwie gerade die Speerspitze des Guten, ja?
Aber allein allein, dass sie das tun.
Macht einfach so ein schlechtes Bild von von der Politik, von den Leuten, die in solchen äh Bereichen arbeiten. Das ist einfach nicht,
schön. Ja, das ist einfach das ist einfach ein rücksichtsloser Schaden, der hier an dem an dem Vertrauen in die Demokratie in Kauf genommen wird.
Der wird ein ganz toller Mensch sein, der Herr Strophe, bin ich mir ganz sicher. Aber,
Wie sieht das denn aus? Wie sieht das denn aus? Und wie sieht das aus, wenn die wenn die dir einerseits erzählen, sie würden mit der Luca-App kein Geld verdienen und dann holen die sich so einen als,
PR. Ich meine wer will toll? Wer wer soll bitte teurer sein als als Lobbyist und PR-Manager, als jemand, der Staatssekretär und Büroleiter des Kanzlers war? Was willst du denn noch?
Na ja, vielleicht äh vielleicht liegt ja Smudo holt ja Smudo jetzt seine seine Ersparnisse unterm Kopfkissen vor und haut jetzt einfach äh für ein Lobby drauf. Da geht sie hin die ganze GEMA-Kohle.
Also das ist einfach, das ist einfach kein schönes Bild, ja und ähm,
das ist ja enttäuschend. Naja jedenfalls äh Luca also hier gibt's ja einen Artikel auf Netz für Tick Org, wo eben erstens gesagt wird, die Luka App hat jedes Recht.
Das Ding auf anderen äh auf andere Weisen zu vermarkten und deswegen habe ich ja gerade auch diesen äh diese diese Überleitung genommen, weil die natürlich auch da sitzen und denken, tja,
zig Millionen in Stores. Das wäre ja jetzt wirklich schade.
Zu vernichten, ne? Also das Gleiche, was du ja gerade zur Corona-Warn-App sagtest, ne? Und äh die Luka App hat natürlich jetzt, ich meine, die schielen in alle Richtungen,
äh überlegen natürlich auch äh ob sie nicht eine direkt
Kommunikationsschnittstelle zwischen Ämtern und Bürgern werden ähm haben ja jetzt schon irgendwie Speisekarten als äh extra Angebot und Monetarisierungsmöglichkeiten in Richtung der Gastronomie aufgenommen. Natürlich wäre jeder wahnsinnig zu sagen okay äh dieses Projekt wird jetzt erbendet und wir widmen uns
etwas Neuem und versuchen nochmal eine Installationsbasis von ein paar Millionen aufzubauen, ja. Aber aus genau dem Grund,
nur wiederholen, haben wir eben gesagt ist es sehr wichtig, dass du hier die staatliche äh Hoheit hast mit der Corona-Warn-App.
Und wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt, bevor nun ein Unternehmen die Kommunikation für den Staat baut, was ja,
offenbar eines der Kommerzialisierungsziele der Luca App ist, wenn man sich diese Artikel durchliest und auch die Zitate, also der Geschäftsführer Patrick Hennig sagt das ja auch ganz klar
ne, dass er äh sich für unterschiedliche Optionen der Monetarisierung interessiert.
Ähm insbesondere äh Ämterkommunikation. Natürlich willst du da lieber äh selber was bauen.
Also natürlich willst du das in eigener in einer eigenen Hand haben und da
deswegen mache ich das so. Natürlich willst du dann lieber, dass die Corona-Warn-App aufgebohrt wird, als dass die Leute, denen du quasi äh,
Nutzerbasis im Wert von 100 Millionen Euro erzwungen geschenkt hast? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie nennt man das? Wie nennt man das, wenn man jemandem was schenkt, indem man andere zwingt. Er er schwenkt.
Er zwängt, er zwängt. Genau, die haben denen das erzwängt. Ähm,
wenn die dann sagen, guck mal, ihr habt uns hier so und so viel äh Nutzer erzwängt und jetzt äh nutzen wir die, um letztendlich quasi bei allem schon mal 40 Millionen oder 30 Millionen Nutzerinnen.
Ähm Vorsprung zu haben. Tja. Also die Corona-Apps werden.
Endemisch.
Kommen wir zu ähm ja, weiß nicht, gute Nachrichten, also.
Bemerkenswerte äh Nachrichten zumindest aus dem Datenschutzbereich ähm und zwar,
blicken wir einerseits auf Frankreich und andererseits auf den Umgang mit äh was ich mal so Cookie Dark Petterns äh nennen würde. Kennt ihr alle. Ja man kriegt so,
komische Dialoge beim Besuch einer Webseite aufgerufen und dann ist da so ein großer, dicker, fetter Button. Mit hier drauf drücken und alles wird gut und dieses hässliche Overlay, was dir den Zugang zu dem geilen Content
versperrt. Das ist dann auch sofort weg und dann dann melden wir uns auch nie nie wieder.
Oder du bist halt dann aufgeklärter User oder möchtest gerne so ja nee äh möchtest jetzt aber nicht, dass jetzt hier diese ganzen Marketing-Cookies bei mir gesetzt werden und dieses und jenes Unternehmen hier berechtigt ist nochmal Quervergleiche zu meinem Surfverhalten aufzuspannen.
Und dann guckst du so, ja wo ist denn der andere Button, der irgendwie sagt, nein, dann musst du's grollen und dann hast du auf,
Telefon, müsste irgendwie noch das nochmal hoch scrollen und dann scrollst du im falschen Bereich und scrollst in irgend so einer komischen Liste und nicht irgendwie das ganze User in der äh äh Element, so dass es dann den eigentlichen Button aussiehst und dann sind die,
benannt und haben eine andere Farbe und sind kleinere Schrift und ihr ihr kennt das alles, ne. Dark Petterns halt. Hauptsache, man sagt ja zu allem
Und dafür ist jetzt Google von der französischen Datenschutzbehörde CNIL mit weiteren Bußgeldern belegt worden.
Äh und Facebook im Übrigen auch. Also es betrifft beide Unternehmen und äh ja, es wurde schlicht und ergreifend festgestellt, dass es halt Nutzerinnen und Nutzern äh auf Webseiten der beiden Unternehmen,
sehr schwer gemacht wurde ähm die Nutzung von Cookies, also Marketing Cocos, abzu.
Nutzung von Marketing, Cocos abzulehnen,
Das äh verstößt gegen französisches Recht. Ich vermute mal, es verstößt vor allem gegen die DSGVO, aber ähm so habe ich das jetzt hier gelesen.
Konzernt und so.
Ist halt auch französisches Recht, aber ich denke mal, dass sich das schon aus der DSGVO ableiten lässt. So, was müssen Sie jetzt zahlen?
Also wir haben jetzt erstmal drei Monate Zeit und können das fixen.
Müssen sie nichts zahlen, aber wenn sie was äh wenn sie es nicht machen oder ich weiß nicht, ob sie's stand hier zumindest nicht. Also hier steht nur, dass äh für jeden Tag Verspätung ein Zwangsgeld in Höhe von 100.000 Euro fällig wird.
Können wir mal ausrechnen? Das wären so 36,5 Millionen Euro im Jahr. Was verdienen Google und Facebook mit dieser Methode?
Also.
Kann schon sein, dass sie sagen, ach ja echt so billig ist das. Dann.
Verzicht war er auf das Ding vielleicht komplett irgendwie. Schalten sie einfach immer ein, wenn das so billig ist. Bei 36,5 Mio im Jahr, machen wir mal locker in Frankreich.
Ja, ich glaube, das sieht aber natürlich schlecht aus, ne? Also die werden natürlich irgendeine Anpassung machen.
Nein nein, Sie sagen auch, Sie machen das und wir kooperieren und alles nicht so schlimm und äh die Datenschutzbehörde hat Google auch schon mal irgendwie fuffzig und einmal 100äh Millionen für ähnliche Verstöße aufs Auge gedrückt, also.
Das greift schon. Wenn man äh dann mal wirklich auch.
Konkret rangeht und vor allem, was heute irgendwie 1hunderttausend bei Verzögerungen sind. Es ist vielleicht beim nächsten Mal dann schon 300.000 und das irgendwie aber ab dem Tag des äh Urteilsspruchs. Also.
Ulsi.
Wenigstens,
geht mal jemand dagegen vor, ja, also das haben wir oder also neu hat das ja auch getan. Ähm äh spezifisch gegen diese äh Dinge sich eingesetzt und ja, also das ist auch tatsächlich ein ein
Irrsinn eigentlich, ne? Wenn du dir wenn du jetzt keinen keinen Browser, Plug-in hast, was was diese Cookie-Concent-Bänder äh weg wegmacht,
Ist ja wirklich skurril. Schon echt äh daneben.
Aber okay, also äh äh wenigstens auch mal von staatlicher Stelle was dagegen. Musste sich ja selber, quasi musste ja dann irgendwie klagen und so was alles, ne.
In Polen,
Ist äh wegen Pegasus gerade äh richtig was los. Also Polen ist ja eh tatsächlich von der politischen Entwicklung her nicht besonders erfreulich insgesamt alles, ne?
Jetzt gerade dieses Mediengesetz, wo sie da äh letztendlich das Ziel hatten, ein unabhängiges Medium mit ausländischen Eignerinnen irgendwie,
ja de facto zu verstaatlichen. Also wir wollten dem entgegen, den er hatte glücklicherweise der Präsident das nochmal abgesägt.
Und äh das Citizen Lab hatte in seiner,
Pegasus, NSO-Pegasus statt zu einer äh Veröffentlichung schon festgestellt und äh eine Amnesty war das halt die, die das quasi festgestellt haben oder beide. Wir Amnesty und Viertel sind da. Das ist ein Satz von NSO-Pegasus gegen Oppositionelle in,
Polen gab und zwei speziellen gegen Roman,
einen prominenten Anwalt, äh der also in der Opposition sich stark macht und eine Staatsanwältin Eva Voschek
äh auch regierungskritisch ist, die gegen die wurde direkt mal mit einem Staatstrijaner vorgegangen und die.
Regierung hatte dann erst eben gesagt, ja das waren ausländische Mächte und jetzt ist aber eben äh rausgekommen,
die haben diesen Staatsttrojaner gekauft und damit ist auch klar, wer den äh eingesetzt hat,
ja und äh gegen die Opposition und das ist Wahnsinn, oder? Ich muss wirklich einfach sagen, das ist halt ein es ist wirklich ein Wahnsinn,
Sowas in einem unserer Nachbarländer passiert, ne? Völlig klar, also diese diese Dinge, vor denen wir immer gewarnen hier, ne, das das passiert dann am Ende äh ja nebenan,
in genau der Form, in einem Land, das Mitglied der Europäischen Union ist, schon irre oder nicht?
Der letzte Teil ist der eigentlich äh,
dramatische Teil. Also das ist irgendwie auf EU-Ebene äh nicht gelingt hier in Polen mal andere Sitten mit durchzusetzen. Das frustriert mich zunehmend von Ungarn fangen wir gar nicht erst an.
Tja und dann also ein ein Themenbereich, den wir ja hier äh äh immer sehr,
vorsichtig um schiffen oder es äh betrifft ja die Crypto Currencies, ne? Und äh das, was da jetzt grade so passiert, also im,
Bitcoin, Eva, NFT und den ganzen äh dem ganzen ähm Sumpf, diesem ganzen Ponysumpf und ähm,
Also es treibt ja wirklich
sehr äh unterhaltsame Blüten, ne. Also ich habe jetzt irgendwie letztens ein ein Plakat gesehen für NASA-Doge. Das ist irgendein Eva-Talken, den man kaufen soll,
es hat wirklich also ich ich glaube, ich kann's zu dieser ganzen Crypto Car C ein eine Sache sagen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es endet, ja? Ich habe ein paar Ideen, wie das ganze Ding endet.
Aber es wird nicht gut enden. So, das das wird nicht gut.
Das ist so.
Auf keinen Fall.
Auf gar keinen Fall. So entweder fackeln wir einfach mit der ganzen Scheiße den Planeten ab,
oder wir bauen alle ganz kräftig hier schöne Infrastrukturen für die ganzen kriminellen Geldwäscher, Steuerhinterzieher und so weiter.
Oder die ganze Kacke geht baden und ihr äh und und am Ende haben wir äh Blut in der Straße. Ne, weil alle ihr Erspartes für ein paar Bits äh aufs Spiel gesetzt haben. Also das sind so die drei.
Und die drei Optionen, die ich sehe, eine positive fällt mir da irgendwie langfristig nicht zu ein.
Nee, das ist ähm schwierig zumal die Leute, die das vor allem jetzt vorangetrieben haben, ihr ihr Geld schon längst gemacht haben,
jetzt eigentlich nur noch die Leute einsteigen, die dann halt künftig bluten werden. Man merkt aber auch, dass das jetzt alles in so einem,
Überhitzungsmodus auch langsam gerät, also jetzt werden sie alle schon panisch und äh die ganze Werbe
Aktivität steigt enorm an und und und lappt auch schon so aus dem Internet äh rüber auf Plakate und äh Fernsehanzeigen. Also so eine gewisse Überhitzung ist schon anzumerken. Wie viel thermischer Raum da noch besteht, bevor es,
kommt, darüber kann man jetzt noch diskutieren. Das ist unter Umständen alles noch ein bisschen länger hin. Aber es ist die Zeichen verdichten sich schon.
Ja aber äh ich glaube, da ist so ein bisschen Luft. Also da auf jeden Fall, wenn du jetzt sagst, Corona ist in zwei Monaten vorbei, würde ich sagen äh diese ganze Krypto-Nummer wird auf jeden Fall nochmal einmal richtig schön nach oben schießen, ja. Also hoffe ich, hoffe ich, sagen wir's mal so.
Ja, das dauert auf jeden Fall noch länger als zwei Monate. Ja klar, du musst ja noch die Gewinner einfahren hier von den Investitionen. Also so schnell jetzt nicht?
Aber ich kann euch nur sagen, ich kann eigentlich nur dazu raten, gebt eure Coins lieber mir. Ähm da sind sie besser aufgehoben. Her damit.
Also ich habe jetzt Bitcoin aus meinen Spendenoptionen rausgestrichen.
Ach echt ja? Äh hast du Norden? Norden Antivirus?
Ähm das läuft jetzt hier eigentlich schon ganz gut seit einiger Zeit, aber ich habe ein bisschen viel CPU-Last. Weiß gar nicht warum.
Also eine der Sachen, die tatsächlich äh.
Eine eine also ein ich finde ehrlich gesagt auch immer die die ehrlichere äh Art des des dessen ist wie man einen erlangten Zugang.
Monetarisiert ist äh
meiner Weare, ja? Also statt einer äh bemächtigt man sich halt eines Computers, eines Sportnetzes oder
eines Superrechners und installiert halt einen meiner, ja, der dann irgendwie Monero meint oder Bitcoin oder weiß der Geier. Und äh ne, für die Zeit, die du diese Maschine im Beschlag hast, ähm,
profitierst du dann eben, ne, weil du,
Energie in nicht mehr wirklich nutzbare Wärme umsetzt und in äh Kryptotaler. So und um das zu verhindern.
Installieren sich viele Leute ein Virenscanner,
Und damit Sie aber trotzdem in den Genuss von Crypto Correncys kommen, hat jetzt Norden,
nun hat die Virus hat jetzt einen Coin Meiner eingebaut in ihren Virenscanner
der wenn du äh im Prinzip äh keine, ne, wenn du jetzt irgendwie gerade nix zu tun hast, dann meint der IFA.
Und ähm dafür, dass er das macht.
Also Norden hat quasi einen Mining-Pool, ja, also den Mining-Pool heißt ja du verwaltest im Prinzip rechnen lasst, du kriegst immer die,
Bestätigung, dass deine äh deine Clients da mitgearbeitet haben und am Ende teilst du die Gewinne unter denen auf.
Also Norden hat jetzt ein IFA-Mining-Pool.
Und der die Software dazu ist in deinem Norden Antivirus drin und sie geben dir sogar deine äh.
Fünfzehn nehmen die nur fünfzehn Prozent von dem was du dort leistest ab als Vieh ja? Also du kriegst immer hin,
85Prozent von dem was du da an Energie wirklich verballerst äh und in IFA umsetzt, kriegst du auch tatsächlich.
Alle die sind alle völlig verrückt geworden, oder? Das ist so so ab absurd, also es sind Aprilscherz.
Ja, also Planeten retten und so klingt natürlich super in den äh ganzen Anzeigen so, aber äh lieber Geld, ne, dass dann doch
äh im Zweifelsfall halt schon äh wichtiger, ne. Also ja mal gucken. Also ich meine, wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr lange dauern und weil du hast die Option auch in der Luca App.
Ja und weißt du, was das Schlimme ist? Mhm, ich habe jetzt nur mal so geguckt, ich habe ja hier auch so einen neuen M eins äh Prozessor, ne? Was der so für Haschraten,
hinkriegt und ich habe jetzt noch nicht so wirklich ausgerechnet, ich glaube das ist nicht äh also das würde man würde den jetzt nicht zu diesem Zweck kaufen und man kann sicherlich besser ähm.
Mit diesen ganzen Grafikkarten und FPGA äh äh FPGAss und Asics und so, die man dafür inzwischen hat, sicherlich besser meinen. Aber natürlich habe ich auch schon überlegt, äh ob man den nicht zumindest, wenn man den nicht an der eigenen Steckdose stecken hat, über Nacht.
Den ich noch einmal ein bisschen was was der denn so erwirtschaften könnte, ne? Ist natürlich Quatsch, aber das natürlich Norden sich das denkt und sagt hm wie viel, wie viel CPU haben wir denn eigentlich da, die wir benutzen könnten?
Und wie viel ist 15 Prozent davon als Revenue für uns?
Macht das vielleicht Sinn, wenn wir hier so einen bei uns mit reinmergen? Und äh ja, haben sie gemacht,
Also das wird irgendwann weißt du, das ist wie wenn du aus irgendwelchen fernen Ländern wie Spanien,
von deren Lotterie hörst und dir denkst, so seid ihr alle bescheuert? Ne, das ganze Land wirft irgendwie Milliarden in diese Lotterie und machen da irgendwie einen riesigen Hype draus oder auch einfach mal die Länder,
wo's wo halt mal Ponys ging's einfach auch wirklich gelaufen sind, ne und die sich dann am Ende halt das das Land in in finanziellen Ruinen geworfen haben, weil sie alle irgendwelche kleinen Täterchen getauscht haben.
So wirst du irgendwann über dieses Krypto reden und sagen OK scheiße Norden Norden hat das da bei sich eingebaut. Das ist doch wirklich.
Also wenn's um Geld geht, kennt einfach niemand irgendwie Scham. Also es ist halt einfach,
äh wenn du Kohle verdienen kannst, dann ist einfach jedes Mittel äh recht und dann wird einfach alles ausgenutzt, was irgendwie zu holen ist und nichts zeigt das besser als diese äh
Welt. Also da wird einfach jede Ressource in Anspruch genommen, egal wie viel Planet dabei drauf geht und es wird auch jede verwegende
Theorie erzählt, um da irgendwie die Agenda durchzusetzen und wenn du dir halt
dieser Community zuhörst, die ist halt auch schon so verblendet, ja, also das ist einfach wirklich schon ein Strohblatt, zwei null.
Was sie sich immer wieder alles aus den Fingern ziehen, was ist denn angeblich für einen gesellschaftlichen Benefit hat, ist halt einfach alles Bullshit. Und ähm,
Das äh könnte nochmal eine heftigere Auseinandersetzung geben, zumal das eben so ein Bereich ist, der prinzipiell eine Menge Geld hat,
Also haben ja schon gesehen, wie wie das in der Politik verfangen hat, ne, mit irgendwie Blockchain in.
Och ja da darf ich ganz dran denken.
Ja, das ja aber so ist es halt,
klar, ne. Gut, ich meine, man kann,
erhalten, dass das ähm komplexe Materie ist, die schwierig zu verstehen ist und wenn natürlich so viele Leute in so einer Branche davon reden, dann muss man zwangsläufig irgendwann mal als Politiker davon ausgehen, dass es auch schon sind, bestimmte Bedeutungen hat, weil wenn du's nicht verstehst, wer bist du denn dann zu sagen, dass das alles nicht wahr ist?
Also das ist äh ja ne so ein,
so ein eigenes äh Problem äh für sich. Aber äh wir raten auf jeden Fall erst mal von der Installation ab. Äh sowohl von der ernorden Antivirus als auch von Norden Krypto.
Krypto Meilern.
Ja, also wenn ihr bereit seid, da irgendwie ähm Geld zu investieren, dann lieber ein T-Shirts von Nokbuch.
Ja. Und dann kann ich noch auf einen kleinen ähm.
Vortrag hinweisen, den ich zusammen mit Karl und Lilit von der Zerforschung gemacht habe, beziehungsweise ist deren Vortrag und ich habe da ein paar Kleinigkeiten, also als Sidekick
beigetragen. Der heißt
Deine Software, die Sicherheitslücken und ich dabei so ein bisschen zusammengefasst, was so beim Melden von Schwachstellen. Die Best Fractice ist einerseits auf der Seite derer DD.
Meldungen machen, andererseits auf der Seite derer, die denen, die mit dieser Meldung umgehen.
Und äh ja, den kann ich an dieser Stelle glaube ich mal empfehlen. Das war anlässlich.
Der RC drei, also der Remote Experience dem Online-Ersatzprogramm für das zweite Ausfallen eines Cares Communication Congress.
Ja
Damit sind wir durch für diese Woche. Euer euer eure erste Sendung des des dritten Jahrs.
Ähm für uns ist es ja schon, dass habe ich vergessen. Was hatten wir jetzt grade? Zehn, ne? Ja.
Das elfte.
Wir sind jetzt im im elften Jahr und ähm ja das wird aber auf jeden Fall diese Pandemie überdauern. Würde ich mal sagen, ne.
Ich wollte übrigens noch äh noch eine Sache, äh ich wollte noch ein anderes Video empfehlen, sorry. Und zwar äh hat äh Helena den typischen Kongressbeitrag gemacht.
Haben wir die die die Teile davon, die haben wir schon beim letzten echten Kongress in Leipzig äh geschnitten.
Und äh der ist sehr lustig. Hast du den schon gesehen.
Ähm weiß ich nicht, nee. Glaube nicht, nein.
Okay, dann dann äh sei der auch äh sei der auch ähm sehr empfohlen,
Ja, der der jährliche Kongressbericht äh ist einfach so äh typisch typisch wie halt über den Kongress berichtet wird mit den Bildern und es geht einfach um alles.
So in den Medien äh über den Kongress berichtet wird, von.
Einfach so ein typischer Typ, wie so ein wie der typische Kongressbericht aussieht, ne?
Jährliche Jahreskongress des CC und so Hacker. Ja, mhm.
C, ne, blinkende Lichter und dann geht es diesmal einfach um alles. Denn äh alles ist kaputt.
Das ist schön. Den kann man dann immer wieder hervorholen und sagen, ja ja.
Es ist schön schön. Da habe ich auch eine Rolle drin, ne? Ganz viele Leute drin, aber eine äh,
Natürlich dann den CEO, der dann sagt, alles ist sicher und CC-Sprecher, also warten's natürlich seit Jahren davor, vor allem und es ist sehr schönes äh sehr schönes Video.
Ich würde euch jetzt auch gern noch einen Podcast äh aus der Mieterebene empfehlen, aber der ist noch nicht draußen. Der kommt aber bald und da wird dann dieses ganze Krypto-Problem auch nochmal umfassend äh.
Ach schade, ich hatte gedacht, das könnten wir hier mal machen.
Ach, das können wir ja sicherlich auch noch ein paar Mal machen, aber jetzt habe ich schon mal äh was aufgenommen. Das kommt dann äh die Tage. Und äh wir können das ja gerne nachbesprechen und noch eine Länge ziehen, durchkauen, fünfzig Mal im Kreis drehen.
Ansonsten meine meine Coin, meine Wallets gibt's alle auf meiner Website.
Bei mir nicht mehr jetzt. Ich bin jetzt ballet free.
Ich habe tatsächlich hier noch so einen Bitcoin Lightning mal äh angemacht. Da weiß ich aber noch nicht genau, wie das geht. Aber da könnt ihr mir auch gerne das erklären möchte, kann mir da Geld hinschicken. Dann gucke ich mir das mal an. Bisher ist da nur nichts passiert.
Wird auch nichts passieren, wie ich dir das schon sage.
Gut Leute, dann äh habt noch eine schöne Zeit und wir hören uns die Tage wieder. Bis bald.
Bis dahin, ciao ciao.